all right so i thought that it would be
fun to just start out with like a spicy
hot take um
uh because i i realize i i've realized
lately i'm just not a controversial
enough person
these are more controversial things to
be more controversial
yeah yeah so uh what i wanna what i
start out by saying is that gerard is
wrong
it's a great way to start to start the
podcast so that's it that's the whole
thing
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
so hello everybody we are back here with
richard roland for one more episode of
uh
of our universal history series and we
are getting very close to holy week uh
as the orthodox and so richard had a
great idea of looking at the
the the different services during holy
week leaving leading up to uh to the the
entombment of christ and how it also
relates to the ritual that we talked
about in terms of the mar the marriage
between the king and the city and how
this all comes together in the symbolism
of holy week so i'm i don't even know
what he's going to say so i'm as curious
as anybody to find out so richard thanks
for coming along again i'm glad to be
here and i plan to say a lot of weird
things that will get you comments on
youtube that's right that's my plan
that's great yeah
um all right so i thought that it would
be fun to just start out with like a
spicy hot take um
uh because i i realize i i've realized
lately i'm just not a controversial
enough person
these are more controversial things to
be more controversial yeah all the
attention yeah yeah so uh what i wanna
what i start out by saying is that
gerard is
wrong
it's a great way to start to start the
podcast so that's it that's the whole
thing all right so for people who don't
know what he's referring to so richard
is referring to rene jira
is an anthropologist who explored the
theme of sacrifice and how sacrifice is
all based ultimately on human sacrifice
and that human sacrifice is the basis of
unity in terms of civilization that that
at least was at the outset the need to
find a scapegoat to put all your
to put all the evils of of a group into
the scapegoat to kill the scapegoat and
in a kind of moment of ecstasy and
violence to refine to find the unity
that that had been kind of falling apart
as all our different idiosyncrasies
started to manifest and it's all related
to the notion of memetic desire which is
the problem of everybody desiring the
same things but there's also being a
lack of resources or lack of possibility
for everyone to have the things they
desire and so by
creating the scapegoat mechanism was a
way to restart
the process and to to avoid it going out
of control and moving into like carnage
and you know massive breakdown of
society
so why is he wrong richard so the reason
he's wrong
is very simply
murder is not the basis of culture
marriage is all right
so
um and and i i'm you know again that's a
little bit of a spicy hot take but um
for me gerard is very much like joseph
somebody like joseph campbell who
famously wrote the hero's journey which
is like
a certain way of understanding mythology
but of course for campbell it's the only
way to understand mythology and a lot of
times what i find is when somebody
really gets plugged into gerard or
really plugged into campbell for the
very first time then it's like they
suddenly they have a hammer and
everything looks like a nail
and they try to explain all the stories
that they encounter uh by means of that
thing right so i don't know that i have
to say i'm curious to see what you're
gonna say because to me the theory that
gerard brings about works very well with
the idea that kane is the founder of
of civilization and so that his
like his founding of the city is is
based on murder and you see that also in
the roman founding as well and in other
cultures but i would like i would think
that it'd be something like murder
moving towards marriage or something
like that oh no that i would agree i
would be okay with that i would all
right yeah so actually i was going to
start out by talking about the founding
of rome all right which would be a great
way to help us understand holy week
um and uh you know yeah so let's get
into it
so um
the way to to kind of to understand holy
week you have to basically
and and
i'll preface this by saying this isn't
just my arbitrary saying oh well holy
week has something to do with marriage
to the founding of a city because that's
literally just the services that's the
text of the the liturgy that's what the
church puts before us so in the orthodox
church in the east we begin the first
four days of holy week in the evenings
we celebrate a matin service which of
course maddens is a morning service um
but typically speaking in the orthodox
church we have this uh let's say like a
sense of urgency that that kind of kicks
in once a big feast starts getting up uh
starts approaching and everything gets
bumped up a little so in paris practice
in the evenings we celebrate something
called the um something called the
bridegroom mountains which is all about
the tomb of christ as his bridal chamber
right so this is not just like an
arbitrary association that i'm making
so to kind of understand what's going on
here you have to know a little bit about
how
cities in the ancient world were founded
and that is that
cities were founded by mythical founders
and i don't actually care
if so if you if you do or do not believe
that these mythical founders were
actually people who existed for the
purposes of the things i'm saying uh
today that's not hugely important uh
what's important is that people in the
ancient world believe this and they
embodied it in a ritual way and it is a
universal pattern that is this is really
a universal pattern that you see in most
cultures they always trace back the
lineage of the king all the way back all
the way back and at some point the first
person in the lineage is a demigod or
some kind of mythological creature and
this is something you see as in tribal
cultures as much as you see in
mesopotamia or in rome or whatever
culture you're thinking of yeah you have
you have uh you have a mythical founder
this is a guy who who
founded your city this guy has some
connection to the gods
and uh and basically you could say the
goal of every king after
him is to embody
that founder
right to make that founder present to
the city again
so um
there's a a historian who wrote a ton of
stuff about this um and he said uh he
says um he he's looking at he was
looking at greece and italy in this sort
of the city-state period i know that
typically speaking we think of like
greece and we think of democracy we
think of italy we think of the roman
republic or the roman empire but there's
a period before all of that
when uh there were there weren't empires
there were just these city-states and
each city-state was ruled over by a king
and uh he says that a well-known fact in
the history of greece proves in a
striking manner that in the beginning
the kingly office belonged to the man
who set up the hearth or the altar of
the city
so this is really important the basis
for
kingship in the ancient world
is priesthood
and if you kind of
if you if you
if
for a lot of people especially if you're
from an evangelical background you maybe
you don't know a ton about kingship in
the ancient world but and so most of
your experience of what kingship in the
ancient world
means
uh comes from reading the old testament
right which is the which is the series
of ancient texts which the most people
have read right the thing about the
thing about that though is that the
kingship of ancient israel and judah was
atypical in a lot of ways or at least
the kingship of judah was atypical in a
lot of ways the kingship of israel after
the kingdoms were divided was actually
super typical in a bunch of ways
but
the original basis of kingship was that
the king was the priest he was the high
priest of the people he was the one who
was supposed to mediate between the
people and the gods
and
we see we actually see one version of
this in scripture which is melchizedek
yeah and melchizedek is both a priest
right and a king and you see that of
course those powers get separated and
for good reason
in in in history uh but there is a sense
in which those that kind of stand above
right the highest versions of these have
the two positions united in one figure
and that's why that's why christ is the
priest after the order of melchizedek
right he rejoins these things actually
we're going to talk a whole lot about
things that sort of get split or divided
right and then the thing to to know is
christ unites these things in in himself
right
even these different mythographical
patterns or or patterns uh that we're
talking about even things like the
hero's journey and gerard's scapegoat
theory and these things like this
uh those theories are incomplete in and
of themselves because they don't explain
everything
um and they don't they don't fit
you could say all the information that
we have but then you can also see how
you if you go to the story of christ you
sh you you should find those
in the story of christ like every every
pattern that's a real pattern is in the
story of christ okay
so um so the king is the guy who sets up
the hearth he's the one who sets up the
fire um and here's a nice little bit of
etymology which i think you'll enjoy
jonathan he's the one who sets up the
focus
for the city where the latin word focus
comes from comes from a really ancient
indo-european root that has to do with a
lot of our words for light like photon
or photo or you know
uh come from that same ancient
indo-european root but the word focus in
latin means the hearth yeah means like
the family hearth or the temple the
temple heart in other words uh the focus
is an altar
yeah and you can understand that at
least in that circumstance it makes
sense because the heart was actually a
fire so you can imagine like in your
house or in right in the space that is
where most of the light would come from
would be from the center so light would
actually move out from the center into
the the periphery of the of the space
and so you it's really like a cosmic
image to kind of un to understand it
that way right and hearth hearts are
also always alters in the ancient world
this is the other thing people have to
remember like your family hearth like
the fireplace in your family that from
which warmth comes and therefore life
right in the cold european winter um
that's also where your food is cooked
all these different things that hearth
is also an altar and you have your
family gods there so if you read the
aeneid which we've talked about before i
think in our very first universal
history video together
um if you read the aeneid what's the
whole thing that aeneas is trying to do
he's trying to take the household gods
from troy his household god's from troy
he's trying to bring them to this new
place that the gods have established for
him which is going to be
italy and of course
uh aeneas found the city of alba longa
um and it's from obalonga that uh
eventually the founders of rome will
come which we'll talk about here in just
a second so the ritual crowning
of a new king
is basically you could say it's supposed
to be a repeat of this first founding
it's supposed to be a ritual marriage
between the king and his city
and this ritual marriage is handled
differently in different cultures if you
want some good examples of this uh you
can just go study the life of alexander
the great who we've also talked about
he's a it's one of these really liminal
figures a lot of connective tissue in
the symbolic you know world or the
universal history goes back to alexander
and one of the things that alexander
would do when he come whenever he came
to a new city is he would do whatever
you needed to do in that city to
become
the
new founder of the city right to become
the new
uh the the son of the most high god of
that particular city right so when he
goes to thebes he does this ritual
sacrifice to the apis pool um in a lot
of places in the in the like ancient
mesopotamia where there's a lot of
fertility cults um to become the king of
the city you actually ritually spend a
night
with the city like like that they take
the marriage to the city to like a
really kind of a literal level um and of
course this is you know consummated
usually with like a temple prostitute um
everyone in alexander's story did they
tell did they talk about that i don't
think i don't think i don't think that
comes up in alexander's story
specifically but a lot of canaanite
cities and like if you look at rituals
for crowning like kings of babylon and
things like that it's that's that that
is very much there so yeah yeah so what
i'm what i'm just trying to say is like
there are a lot of different examples in
alexander's story of how do you go
somewhere and become
to become the king of a city you also
become the son of the gods and you also
become kind of you ritually re-embody
the founder uh of the city and this is
something by the way caesar augustus who
probably we should do just a video on
him at some point if we're going to do
course yeah because he's so important to
universal history right uh another but
this is something he's really conscious
of and so
this is you know part of why uh he
commissions the indian right um this is
part of why he's
um but but also some other ways that
we'll talk about in a moment he he
really tries to consciously create this
effect
of being married to the city of rome
yeah we also people don't realize that
the emperor was pontifex like the
emperor was also high priest in rome you
have images of augustus you know wearing
more military guard but you have images
of augustus where he's actually wearing
a priestly garment like
his cloth over his head and we don't we
don't we don't recognize but he's
actually dressed as a priest
yeah so
in in a city like rome which is
significantly less ancient than babylon
for one thing
um it's probably founded you know right
around the time of maybe the prophet
isaiah something like that um so you
know pretty pretty recent as cities go
um but uh it's
ritual prostitution was never so much a
thing in rome itself um um there are
places in like classical the greco-roman
world that did practice ritual
prostitution but it wasn't so much a
thing in the city of rome itself
however um you could say you could say
that's like a feature of like the
ancient fertility cult and rome is like
a little more
man i don't want to say modern but it's
like it's because that's not even like
correct in any way but but it's like
it's a little more recent it's a little
more up to date right
so what rome does have they don't have
ritual prostitutes but what they do have
is the
vestal virgins right so the vestal
virgins um
are dedicated to the service of vesta
vesta is one of the hearth gods yeah um
that and in fact her her temple or her
altar was sometimes called the trojan
hearth
right so she's one of the hearth gods
that um sort of the hearth god that
aeneas was trying to rescue from the
ruins of troy and reestablish his
civilization so think back to this idea
in the ancient world that the founder of
the city is the one the king is the one
who establishes the city's hearth yeah
right and of course you could say if the
if the hearth like the literal fireplace
in your home
if that's your heart then that's your
altar the city's hearth is the altar
where everybody comes to yeah to worship
so the vessel virgins are basically
they're the the priestesses they're
usually at one point there were two and
then i think later there were like six
uh but they're the ones who are uh given
the specific task of
tending the fires the hearth fires at
the temple of vesta which are never
supposed to be allowed to go out right
and actually the the cult of esta is
pretty much the last religion in pagan
religion in rome to be
abolished people held onto it i think a
lot longer than they did basically any
of the other gods after the conversion
of christianity i think it's something
because it was linked to the very
existence of the city right yeah some
people said well if the hearth fires
ever go out then rome will fall right
um
uh so
you you have uh you have these vestal
virgins and the important thing to sort
of know is that ria who's the
she's she was a vestal virgin of alba
longa
she's the mother of romulus and remus
so the story is is that she was you know
obviously as a vessel virgin the
the two important words there are vestal
and virgin
um and
uh so if you're a vessel virgin and you
suddenly become pregnant um they had all
kinds of creative ways of killing you um
actually
and in genuinely creative ways because
in ancient rome even if a vessel virgin
defiled herself you were still not
allowed to to like harm her in any way
so they had to come up with these
special rules for how would you bury a
vestal virgin alive because then you're
not harming her she's just stops she's
gonna die underground
yeah but
side note um i i once wrote uh for
school i once uh this is why you should
homeschool it's because i once wrote a
whole paper on methods of execution in
the ancient world so i just the stuff is
always jingling around yeah somewhere
but but they would but uh so they had
these two laws one is they couldn't
normally they would execute somebody by
strangling in ancient rome so they
couldn't do that because she's a vessel
virgin but they couldn't bury her alive
because there were laws against burying
someone alive within the precincts of
the city of rome
um and this is tied to a lot of other
things that we probably don't have time
to talk about today but um but typically
speaking building when you were building
a new building uh there was a there's an
extremely ancient practice of like you
bury a slave
for its foundations and uh the romans
didn't like that um and so they said
well we can't bury somebody alive so
what they did is they build an
underground little house
and they put like two or three days
worth of food and water in there and
then they put the ver the
yeah they sealed it and so that so they
weren't burying her alive and they
didn't kill her she just died of
starvation which is not a great way to
go it's great yeah yeah yeah so uh
romans everybody all right so maria yeah
so rhea
is the vessel virgin of of uh of alba
laga she's raped by mars and so she has
to run away uh she's raped by the god
mars and she becomes pregnant people
find out she's pregnant she used to run
away or they'll kill her he'll kill her
and then of course she goes out into the
wilderness and has her children romulus
and remus
um and so the founder i just want to
kind of point this out and i don't want
to point this out in
well there's no way for me to point this
out with giving some people
um
but the founder of rome
is both the son of a virgin
sort of
and also the son of a god yeah right
although obviously he's not virginally
born
and there is also
to give the gerard folks their due here
there's also a murder
of the son of a virgin and the son of a
god that is a part of the founding myth
of rome right um
so for those who don't know i'm sure
everybody knows who's watching this but
romulus kills remus yeah in order to
found the city yeah if you don't like
what have you been why are you watching
even our podcast if you don't know that
yeah like what rock or vessel virgin
uh entomb have you been living under um
yeah if you don't know that so uh uh
so new roman kings when a new roman king
was made and the romans did have kings
for a long time when a new roman king
was made he'll be brought through the
gate of the city
up to the city's high place the
capitoline hill and of course the
highest point
of ancient cities is always where they
would put the temple right yeah
um and the marriage would be consummated
between the king
and the city of rome the marriage would
be consummated on the capitoline hill um
and different again different cultures
have different ways of doing this the
way they would do it is they would they
would seat the uh
the king in a chair and then they would
basically stand there and wait and there
would be an auger there and they would
wait for the gods to show by flashes of
lightning or certain bird flight
patterns various things like this um i'm
not an auger so yeah just you know you
can't read them
yeah yeah
and um
the uh the marriage would be consummated
when the gods gave their ascent in other
words
the gods are
the gods are presiding
over the marriage
right they and and they give their
ascent and then the marriage takes place
and this
this caused a kind of a a relationship
where
even though it was like
a totally platonic or like totally
celibate thing
um where the king was sort of you could
say ritually married to the vessel
virgins right so the vessel virgins they
embody
and it they're really the vestal virgins
are really un important to understanding
how rome thinks of herself
which is sort of as the
well gosh darn it as sort of the
unwedded bride right because because the
vestal the whole thing uh uh with vet
going on with vesta is that she's she's
this virginal goddess but also somehow
she's a mother right she's the mother
who's never been violated that's how
rome thought of herself right so she
thought of herself as like a mother to
the other cities and the lands that she
conquers
but also one who had never been wedded
none no one who had never sort of been
taken as a bride right never been
conquered by never been conquered yeah
exactly and um and so
when the
when the kings are driven out and
abolished when the tarkins are driven
out of rome what they do is they take
all of these things that in every single
ancient culture sort of naturally
uh manifested in the king and they split
those up and they break those things
apart right and so one of those roles is
of the high priest the pawn effects
maximus
but they still did a very similar ritual
to this for instance whenever they would
make a a new consul and a lot of roman
historians talk about this
when caesar augustus when he becomes
what he becomes right what he basically
does
is to take all these little titles all
these little manifestations of the
city's authority and actually to bring
them back together and kind of reunite
them into a single person
so one of the ways that he does this is
that there was this law that the
pontiff's maximus has to reside in a
publicly owned house in other words if
you're the high priest you have to live
in a house that the city owns not your
own the point is you're not supposed to
be
uh accumulating wealth and power to
yourself right you're supposed to be
just operating on behalf of the city
and so what he does to kind of do an end
run around this is that he keeps his pro
his private house but he gives part of a
way to the vestal virgins and creates a
new shrine of vesta there in his house
so some of the vestal virgins come to
live in caesar's house
symbolically right they're his
wives yeah right so what is he doing
he's sort of symbolically marrying
himself to the city of rome
um and uh this very this massively
strengthened the connection between
augustus
and
not just the roman state
not just like the the the instruments of
political power but it hugely
strengthens his relationship between
rome and
everything about rome like
like
symbolism religion all these different
things right and so so you could sort of
see augustus is now sort of the husband
of rome
and that's basically how augustus
becomes king without becoming without
ever calling himself king right in fact
he never really called us himself
emperor for that no
yeah he calls himself uh uh you know the
first citizen the prince the first
citizen yeah it's amazing augustus is an
astounding character super brilliant
brilliant guy yeah
yeah okay so that's that's a little bit
about city founding rituals um and
there's a whole lot more uh if you want
to go down rabbit trails on this and
kingship in general there's a book i
think you can find the pdf on
on the internet for free because it's
very old book but it's just called the
ancient city a study on uh the religion
laws and institutions of greece and rome
um and um it's it's a really really old
book that i think was recently
translated into english in like 2001 i
want to say but you can find a pdf of
this out there if you want to read a lot
more about this
so
i'm going to kind of pivot from there
not so much pivot but transition from
there into talking about
holy week
so holy week
again we start out with this idea so
we started with this idea of of the
bridal chamber of br of and with this
the service of bridegroom mountains
right
and so we have uh christ the bridegroom
as
kind of the central figure um and
there's there are several
there's several parables about
um
i was just looking around i have a
christ christ the bridegroom
image around here we'll show it yeah
yeah we'll put one up this is a really
important icon this will be the icon
that will actually be in the church for
these four days
um this is a really important icon
because it shows christ
as a king
but as like
a suffering king yeah because it shows
him as a king but he's got the he's got
the scarlet robes that the soldiers put
on him and he has the crown of thorns
and he is the reed that they put in his
hand it's of course this is one of those
things where they're you know symbolism
literally happens jonathan
yeah where where like they're doing
these things to him to mock him but
actually what they're doing is revealing
him for who he is right
and so but if you think about that
narrative uh the basic narrative of the
city founding myth the king comes to the
city
he uh right and it's born to understand
that it starts with the with the palm
sunday yeah
triumphal entry yeah so the king comes
to the city and he enters in this
triumphant way right uh people acclaim
him people you know and you could say
it's the
it exactly corresponds if you've ever
been to an eastern orthodox wedding it
exactly corresponds right to that the
entry into the narthex when the bride
and the groom meet
right and they're still on the narthex
right still at the gate uh but they meet
and they're sort of like joined and
they're betrothed right that's what palm
sunday is it's sort of like the
betrothal right and then christ ascends
to the high place of the city of rome
sends to the hype or not of rome of
jerusalem he sent to the high place of
his city this is i mean he's
christ is both
you know divinely
you know he's he's yahweh the god of
israel so this is his city this is
zion is the city where god put his name
right so this is his city but also this
is the city because it's the city of
david who is christ's ancestor according
to the flesh right so christ is christ
is the king right he's the king
uh he's the king both
you know originally
you know why why does the kingship and
the why is the kingship and the priest
who had split out
originally well
in in the mosaic law it's because god is
supposed to be their king yeah right and
so
on by that standard christ is king
of he's king of the jews right he's king
of israel but then
by the kind of the new davidic you know
the relatively speaking new
uh institution of kingship in in israel
right the davidic kingship christ is gay
so this is his city he comes as king and
people know it people acknowledge him
um you know
hosanna to the son of david right
so he comes up and he comes up to the
high place in and in the synoptic
gospels matthew mark and luke
uh what we see
is that after his triumphal entry as he
comes up to the high place the holy
place the mountain of you know of god
the temple in the midst of the city
he comes up there but what does he find
he finds it's become corrupt he finds
that it has become
uh you know there are
it's supposed to be a house of prayer
but you turn it into a den of thieves
right and this is when he drives the
money changers out of the temple and
this is not the gospels
um it's right after his triumphal entry
so the thing that's supposed to happen
if you're kind of following this ancient
blueprint
is that christ would ascend and he would
consummate his relationship with the
city
in the temple right you could say this
would be something like
going into the temple and offering a
sacrifice or as god going to the temple
and accepting worship accepting
sacrifice and what he does instead
is
um is to drive the money changers out
but in a way he also restores the heart
like yes restoring the center he's he's
cleaning it out like he's he's removing
the ash and he's making it
like pristine again you could say
yes but this is also like the basis of
now the jews are like okay we really do
have to kill him this time yeah right so
it so this is like the basis you could
say it's always when you hit somebody's
uh
pocketbook right this is the basis of
this is the basis of the the final
rejection of the jewish people the
jewish religious leaders the priestly
class this is the fight this is the
basis of their final rejection of christ
so much so that they are willing
to
do what has to be done to kill him
so christ goes out of the city
immediately after approaching the temple
he leaves the city of jerusalem and as
it just says kind of a very interesting
note there's not a single time in the
gospels that i've ever ever been able to
find uh and petite talks about this in
his book as well
that christ spends the night in the city
of jerusalem as an adult never happens
and um so he doesn't consummate his
relationship he cleanses it so you could
say he restores it to his virginal state
yeah right but then he doesn't
consummate the relationship he goes
outside of the city and he stays the
night he usually spends the night in
bethany in fact most of the time when
jesus is in jerusalem he's like teaching
or preaching in jerusalem during the day
but then he's going back to bethany to
lazarus's house yeah and that's where he
stays
what you see is this city founding
ritual that is sort of like aborted it
sort of goes wrong and the thing that it
culminates in is you could say a murder
leading to a marriage okay the thing
that culminates in is what his bridal
chamber outside the city outside the
walls of jerusalem and his bridal
chamber is the tomb
right and so this is the this is the way
that the church
presents it to us and encourages us to
think about it is
is of christ's burial in the tomb among
other things
right is his entry into his bridal
chamber where he consummates his
relationship not with the physical city
of jerusalem but with his new city which
is the city of god the heavenly
jerusalem which is the church
and that's the
you could say that's like the core idea
of holy week
yeah and it's
if you start to think about it it's so
it's just it's always like every story
that is related to christ it always just
smashes so many things if you start to
think about the relationship
um you know between
this murder this this sacrifice that
happens
and how it's outside the city and then
also when christ dies it says that you
know the veil of the temple is ripped
and so he goes
his his bride chamber is the tomb and
it's at the same time the the holy of
holies at the same time so he actually
goes it's like he fills up he goes all
the way up and all the way down at the
same time because you know when he's on
the cross he says right tomorrow you'll
be with me
in paradise which is like which is a
weird thing to say because he's gonna
spend it you know he's gonna spend some
time in the tomb there um but there's a
mystery happening where
he both in like you said consummates his
actual
kingship and priesthood in going into
the holy of holies and into the garden
of eden but then also reaches the bottom
of the world and kind of makes the whole
world his kingdom you could say
so
here's the uh and when you said mention
the the tearing of the veil this made me
think about this um
here's one that i've been kind of
pondering over the last couple of weeks
as as we're coming up on and i think as
we're recording this western christians
are already in their holy week yeah um
um
but as we're coming up on holy week so
something i've been thinking about is on
holy monday
the scripture readings and the
liturgical service focuses our attention
on joseph the patriarch
right and this you know um you know
technicolor joseph right um
my brother was in a production a couple
of years ago of of the the
amazing technicolor dreamcoat which is a
which was awesome uh it was a lot of fun
but uh yeah so
joseph
has all of this
right of course the story of joseph is
the story of christ yeah very betrayed
by his brethren right but something i've
never really noticed before right is
this
joseph goes into the he goes into the
the
house of potiphar right
and he's there in the house of potiphar
and then he
um
who who does seem to have like some kind
of a priestly role right
um and so because he's a eunuch which is
weird
yeah so he goes to the house of is
potiphar eunuch i think so i don't i
don't think no he's not okay well i
don't think so i don't think so to fact
check that yeah that could explain why
his wife was trying to get with joseph i
guess but anyway
i'm sorry all right that's okay so
so um
so you got joseph he goes from the house
with pothofar who is this priestly
individual
and um
while he's in the house of potiphar
right the the wife of potafar tries to
seduce him right
um and so there's a
consummation that is supposed to happen
or not supposed to happen but there's a
consummate well the consummation that
should happen right is between potiphar
and his wife but there's something
impure
in the relationship right there's
something missing or something off yeah
so what does joseph do joseph flees
and when he flees
his veil his garment is torn
right you know torn from him in this
case
um but just kind of thinking about the
the symbolic resonance between that and
christ coming to the coming to the high
place coming to the temple but it's
impure because the people of god have
have become [ __ ] they've prostituted
themselves out right they're
they're they're they're serving mammon
right and so they and so christ leaves
and when he he leaves you know what
happens his garments are torn but also
like the veil of the temple is torn you
know kind of kind of showing
you know among other things god's not
there he's over here
but um yeah so there's a lot of there's
a lot of really interesting resonance i
think um more than
more than i think i i i i
initially realized you know even growing
up as a little kid you can read the
story of joseph and be like oh
this is obviously you know a type of
christ but
i think there's also a way in which
there's a surprising idea that i see in
the story of joseph obviously than sort
of christ is that there's a manner in
which this transaction which happens
is a way to save this
egyptians yeah first
and so it's like you you change those
people that are in even like if you read
saying greg
are images of of this world of death of
this world of animality this world of
the stranger you know he you know saint
gregory talks about the relationship
between the egyptian and circumcision
and like killing the egyptian has to do
with circumcision like all of this
imagery is very strong and so there's a
sense in which christ goes
there's a transaction which happens
because the the
the jewish representatives sell him to
rome so that they can kill him and then
they kill him because obviously the jews
don't kill jesus directly the the romans
physically do
and then he goes into death
and there's something about that which
is related to him becoming the king of
the romans yeah well and that's the
thing i kind of wanted to point it out
point out i mean the whole basic idea of
universal history is the way that
is the stories that we tell about
ourselves as cultures and cities things
like this
the ways that they're sort of caught up
into the kingdom of god and even all the
stuff we're talking about with romulus
and remus and the vessel virgins and
augustus and all this stuff like there's
a
there's a cringy internet fedora wearing
atheists read on all of this which is
like oh see christianity is just like a
bad collage of all this other stuff but
if you really understand what's going on
uh what you can see is is again if
there's a true pattern you'll find it in
the story of christ right there's no
there's no pattern that's true that's
not there in his story
there's also a working out of this
pattern which is bringing into it
bringing it to a universal level right
it's like it's taking local realities
and things that are somewhat off like a
good example would be let's say the
relationship between mars and vesta and
uh yeah
yeah yeah maria there's something which
is pointing towards christ but which is
off and we know it's off because right
like it's because obviously she's still
if she's raped by god she's not a virgin
and so
there's something that and she has to
you know there's something that doesn't
make any sense and so in the story of
christ
the best of that story gets taken in
there and then gets solved like the
problem gets solved in terms of the
relationship between god and and and
virginity and how that brings about the
true son of god ultimately
and that's something like you said which
it's i think that for us for a lot of
orthodox and for you and i
not only is that not a problem but it is
like a beautiful it's like a beautiful
grand
narrative poem that is uni that is
happening all over the world that is
coming into its its powerful resolution
yeah
it's a feature not a bug
exactly it's a future feature not a bug
yeah that that whole idea that
that uh you could say like to manifest
the true king
you would need someone
who who is both a virgin and a mother
and
uh
but and to manifest the true king you
need someone that is divine and human
yeah and that and the way it's presented
in all the ancient stories it's like a
weird hybrid he ends up being a strange
hybrid and so you know there's something
off about the character always um and
it's always like uh it's always like
someone someone's married and then the
god comes and takes them or there's it's
always like a rape of some kind it's
like it's like an imposition of the god
on reality which brings about and so
that's why civilization itself has
violence at its core i mean the you know
rama
remus and romulus are the sons of mars
and there's a reason why rome has such
blood on its hands like
and that blood is not only there but
it's glorified it's part of its story
there's something which is conquering
nature is so so prevalent uh and so that
gets transformed with christ into
something which is
far more powerful and then like i said
way more universal because it it brings
a story to its resolution and avoids the
trappings of the of the other versions
yeah so so tuesday
the focus maybe this ties in i don't
know i'm still kind of mulling over this
one so maybe you can help me understand
it
the focus for tuesday the gospel reading
is about the baron fig tree right christ
goes to the fig tree and the thing is he
comes to the fig tree and it even tells
us in the text
that that this is not the right time for
figs
right um
but he comes to the victory and he finds
it fruitless
and so he curses it right and then the
fig tree withers
um
to me this has to do with this has
mostly to do with the removing of
garments yeah this is what's going on
it's like
christ is going back into one of the
things christ is doing doing many things
one of the things he's doing is he's
going back into
the temple going back into paradise so
as he goes back into paradise he removes
the fig garment you know he he he
removes the garments of fig leaves and
that's the cursing of the fig tree
from the syrian says it that way like he
sees the cursing of the fig tree as the
removal of the of the fig garments i've
forgotten that so that that goes really
well then with a couple of things one is
is obviously the focus on the previous
day is joseph losing his garment to
potiphar's wife right which is the
another way that garment of skin is
being removed um and then also
the focus of bridegroom matins is this
idea that
i'm not
ready for the wedding right i'm not
ready for the bridal chamber why because
i have no wedding garment
right and so there's also there's also a
um
you could say an acknowledgement the
whole purpose of of the holy week
services for the first four days
starting sunday evening uh the whole
focus of holy holy week services is to
to sort of reveal our nakedness right to
acknowledge our own nakedness before god
right and also remember that in the
entry into jerusalem there's also
removal of garments
people take remove their garments their
outer garments and put their rights
as he walks into the city so all this
idea of removing garments and finding
glorious garments is something which is
preparing itself if you understand what
baptism looks like in the orthodox
tradition and how it works you can
understand that all this is coming
together right and of course this is all
that angle is all headed towards holy
saturday which is the traditional day
for the baptism of catechumens in the
orthodox church obviously nowadays we do
it on different days but
originally holy saturday that's that's
kind of the day
yeah so the next day uh the focus on um
um the focus on a holy tuesday evening
is the uh
um
or the i guess that yeah the focus on
the focus on tuesday holy tuesday the
focus is on the entry into the temple
and the cleansing of the temple which
we've talked about yeah right
um
and of course you could say like trade
itself is a garment of skin for a
culture right um you know that's why
we're always talking about the economy
the economy the economy right um this is
kind of you know money trade things like
this
um
things that aren't really generative
right uh trade doesn't actually create
things it just moves them around yeah um
uh and um this is why
among other things this is why uh uh
lending out money at interest is
associated with sodomy in for instance
dante's divine comedy right um because
because neither neither are they're
punished in this circle of hell because
neither one of them are generative right
um and then this brings the focus this
focus uh sort of culminates on holy
tuesday evening
uh when we read the parable of the ten
virgins
um and of course this is the whole idea
of getting ready for the
getting ready for the wedding yeah
um and then holy wednesday evening
we focus on the betrayal of christ by
judas
which i'd be interested to
there's a lot going on with judas right
like it's one of the main
one of the main images in christianity
right is christ betrayal by judas um of
course it's one of the main things there
are multiple psalms that
prophesy this pre-figure this right
and um you've got judas
um
there's a there's a you know an image
that's just sort of fixed in my mind of
uh at the at the mystical supper judas
getting up and he puts on his cloak and
he goes out right you know and um
and then of course he's using what is he
betraying christ for he's trading christ
for money exactly right right yeah
absolutely an idea of exchange right and
the same idea that was in the temple
right it's the idea of like exchange for
a sacrifice right
you know so
so yeah so all of this stuff is is
coming and it's kind of all obviously
this is gonna culminate in the uh
in uh
the service of good friday
which in both the east and the west uh
it's been historically celebrated
slightly differently
um
by the way i just want to say one thing
but i'm not going to explain it but it's
okay i've talked about this in other
videos i i think i talked about it
before but but there's a removal of
clothing at the time of judas's betrayal
as well
because because
who is supposedly saint mark which is
right not named as he was running away
from the mount of olives his garment
gets removed and he runs down down to
the hill naked basically what a weird
little detail what a very strange gospel
st mark yeah that's right yeah but it's
important i think it has to do with it
there's something about there's
something about a weird like this
removing of garment and shame it's not
clear but there's there's there's
definitely a pattern because because you
understand the amount of olives as i've
talked about this how in the
when christ goes up and the the
disciples stay down at the bottom and
they they fall asleep that this is
really a very powerful cosmic image of
going up towards the holy place and then
people forgetting it's it's almost moses
going up and people worshiping the
golden calf at the bottom of the
mountain it's a version of that story
and so the idea that as they run away
and someone as their run is scattering
you know as christ is being betrayed
then there's this strange moment where
uh it's almost this the garment is
removed
i
and it's so it's so like if the
categories don't they just smash it's
hard yeah yeah everything jumbles up
right at the passion you know just like
symbolically it's very difficult to you
could say like disentangle it because
it's that because there's so much going
on and there's things that seem to
signify two opposites at the same time
constantly two opposites at the same
time so it's like
you know is it the nakedness of shame
of noah right in his tent that his brain
is happening or is it the same with
christ on the cross himself is is his
nakedness on the cross the nakedness of
shame or is it the nakedness in the
garden and the answer is it's both at
the same time both yeah yeah but it's
just hard
you can't really hold it in your mind
when you're not when you're thinking
about it well even even things like so
you know judas goes to who does he go to
to make the exchange he goes to the he
goes to the temple
right he goes to the temple to make that
exchange yeah right and then later on
when uh there it's it's when they're at
the you know
if not at the temple itself they're in
the precincts of temple because they're
the the house of the high priest that's
when peter betrays christ
right um and so you have
yeah this this whole
it's where we're not going to
disintegrate the whole thing we're
supposed to stay on the line of the
bridegroom i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
there's so much going on there's so many
so many things just converge all at once
i mean this is the master pattern this
is the that's right it's the basis of
the universe existing right as this
moment so um
and so on thursday night um to talk a
little bit about what we do in our
liturgical practice
um
you know on thursday evening what we do
is uh is we do this beautiful service
called the twelve gospels in the
orthodox church
um and um i think that i think that uh
they do the foot washing in in uh
the monday thursday in in some western
practices some i don't yeah yeah but uh
but that's the night that i think that's
the night that it happens i think or no
isn't it the same night as the betrayal
um
thursday i think it's on i think it's i
think it's on thursday but uh you know i
don't yeah yeah we didn't actually do
any of that stuff when i was a
protestant at the church church that i
was in you know we had an easter service
but that was it
um and so the only liturgical tradition
i've spent
a lot of really enough time to really
form me in any way is obviously been in
the eastern orthodox church though i've
studied a lot and i'm a about
various different ways that this is done
so in um
in the eastern orthodox search on holy
thursday night we're actually having
it's a friday morning service right
uh and what we do is we read the entire
passion gospel account from all four
gospels this is a pretty long service it
takes quite a while and it's inner it's
interspersed with some really beautiful
hymnography that is
um a lot of it is from the perspective
of the virgin
which is
not incidental to what we're talking
about today right um
much of that hypnography and the
hypnography of holy week in general is
sort of walking along with her as she's
watching her son right
where he's the he's the bridegroom whose
bride rejected him right and then she's
the uh she's the unwedded bride right
and so there's uh
there's there's just a lot of really
beautiful inner play between them in
those hymns and i i always find those
hymns to be the most moving and
beautiful part of holy week for me yeah
so
at the end of this we do this thing and
they it's a it's a holy friday thing in
both the east and the west in in you
know medieval times
uh we do this thing keeping in mind that
for us thursday night is at that point
friday morning we do something called
creeping to the cross uh that's what it
was called in england
this is one of the main things that the
reformers were trying to do away with
um
it's a whole different conversation to
talk about the ways that for instance
the english reformation changed the way
that holy day was celeb
the holy week was celebrated in england
but one of the main things that the
protestant reformers in england were
really keen to get rid of was this
practice of creeping to the cross which
is basically
in the west they would veil all of the
icons in the church
um
which is you know talking about this
this imagery of failing and unveiling
right
the garments of skins so what they would
actually do at the beginning of lent is
they would they would veil all of the
images in the church and some england i
think there are i know for a fact that
there are still some anglican churches
that do this today i don't think that
this is typically done in
uh like roman catholic parishes like
novus ordo but i could be wrong some of
them might do it i'm not sure
uh but they do they have this practice
of veiling everything and what happens
on holy friday is that they unveil the
cross
and they unveil a cross and there's like
a a ceremony in medieval england there
was a ceremony they would do this and
that the priest would sing
i had the words here somewhere he was
saying behold the wood of the cross on
which hung the savior of the world come
let us worship so he was seeing this
three times and then
while lifting the veil and then once the
veil was lifted um
it's not just a cross obviously it's a
crucifix the whole parish the whole
church would come forward and they would
kiss the feet of christ which is also
something
and at the end of that 12 gospel
services at least in my parish that's
something we do is we come forward at
the end we prostrate before the crucifix
and we kiss christ's feet as sort of as
we go out
um and so this is uh
this is you could say
the moment of the wedding
um and in fact in medieval england uh
this would be
the first kiss the first time that you
actually got to kiss anything in church
all holy week um because they would uh
uh normally in medieval mass
in england they had something called the
pax breed the pox breed the piece it's
like the sign of peace
and it was like uh it's like a little
metal icon and they would pass this
around at the time of the passing of the
piece in uh
in the in the mass it was literally like
something that you passed and you would
kiss it uh and it was a way of
if you were
people in medieval england for instance
didn't take communion except usually
once or twice a year at easter and maybe
christmas right so this was your thing
that you got to do with the liturgy and
actually if you pass it around in the
wrong order it's supposed to be sort of
be passed around in the order of the
social hierarchy of the parish so if you
pass it around the wrong order fights
could break out in the middle of mass um
it's pretty pretty fun times great yeah
yeah good good stuff but um but they
wouldn't pass this during holy week
because christ was betrayed with a kiss
right which is another kind of weird
aspect of the wedding
imagery i think yeah right
um and so uh and so this would be the
first time in a in the medieval west
like that you would actually kiss
something in church all week during the
holy week
and the next day the next day uh the
holy friday
in both the east and the west uh what we
basically do is we have a funeral for
christ
um and so what uh what we do in the
orthodox church today as probably many
people are watching this will know
is that uh we've got a couple of
services one where we're actually sort
of performing a funeral for christ and
so we have an icon called the burial
shroud
um
that we
carry around the building we carry
actually carried around the church there
are psalms you know laments and things
like this that we sing and then we lay
it in this ritual tomb which we've
actually built in the middle of the
church and the ritual tomb has a cool
name in greek which i don't remember
um but they actually had this in the
west as well so
in medieval england they would either
build a temporary sepulcher in the
middle of the church just like we
usually do in our parish practice or
if you had a well-appointed
uh parish in
if you had a well-appointed parish in in
england
um then there might actually be a
permanent sepulcher kind of up by the
altar but kind of off to one side and
that's what was used
and uh an interesting difference in our
practice versus the practice in medieval
england
is that typically speaking we lay two
things to signify christ being in the
tomb
one is this
one is this um
one is this icon this burial shroud that
we talked about which is like
people understand that it's a shroud
it's a shroud but on the shroud is an
image of christ laid in the tomb right
yeah so it's a it's a yes right it can
be painted sometimes it's stitched yeah
it can be a stitched image it depends on
kind of like a meta shroud sort of
because it's like a shroud of a shroud
but then and then we take uh and then we
also take the gospel look we laid on top
of that and then in our parish we also
what we do then is we take the veils
um i know there's probably a better name
for the these but
we take the veils that we would normally
use to veil the eucharist
right
and we actually use those so if you read
the scriptures again
it's interesting to see like think about
this this idea of garments being removed
right because when christ is laid in the
tomb he's wrapped and then there's like
another veil a napkin that's kind of
folded over his face right and a nice
detail is that when jesus leaves the
tomb
uh the
the the wrappings are empty
but the napkin has been nicely folded
christ is
apparently very tidy i don't know what
else to do with that you know
but um
and so
when uh so we when we lay when we lay
christ in the tomb liturgically like
ritually
we
take these two veils right and we place
them one over his face and then i think
one yeah so it's it's a really beautiful
kind of maybe that's just like a slavic
thing or a
microphone i don't know we don't yeah
i've never seen that in our i've never
done posca at any other paris pairs yeah
exactly yeah yeah so somebody out there
who watching this knows a lot more than
i do so maybe you can let us know
um
all right so
in the east or sorry in the west in
medieval england just as an example
again um they had a few different ways
they would do this the first thing that
they would do
is instead of making it uh an icon of
the gospel book they would have the
crucifix which they would take and they
would lay in the tomb
and
um
and then they would also have uh they
would have had a
pre-consecrated host
a eucharistic host
and they actually lay that they would
put that in like a small uh pics is what
it was called like a small little
container and then actually place that
in the tomb as well
some churches there was there's one
church in late medieval england just a
couple hundred years before the
reformation that actually had a very
beautiful elaborate carved crucifix with
a removable compartment in the chest
with a picks in it and so what they
would do for holy friday
is that they would actually remove this
compartment they would put the
consecrated host in that and then place
it back in and lock it up and then put
that in the tube right which is pretty
that's pretty that's it's it's kind of
cool like it's interesting also to think
about the the the um about the the uh
the ark of the covenant and the mana
inside the art you know and the law
inside the ark because i've seen the the
bible on the
when we use the bible but the idea of
putting an actual consecrated piece of
bread there
yeah and um what duffy says uh last last
video i think we talked about i i
mentioned the stripping of the altars
which is a really important um
uh book i think but he says that this
sepulcher
is
the
the interpretive crux
for understanding
uh popular religion in late medieval
england
right the purpose of this sepulcher was
to focus obviously the symbolic focus of
holy week christ cross and passion and
all this but also to reinforce the
doctrine of the eucharist which was
really was already even before the
reformation in england coming under fire
dramatically by people like the lawlers
who
i mean would and these are people who
would go into churches they would steal
pixes and then they would take the host
and they would
trample on it or defile it in some other
way right in a public way to show i
don't believe that there's anything here
right yeah um and so um and so this this
corresponded with the watch that would
be kept over the tomb which is something
we do in the orthodox church today
something they did in the medieval west
as well um and in this watch that they
keep over the tomb
you know there are a couple of things
going on one is it there's then there's
the nice symbolism of like keeping the
watch of the tomb but there's also the
fact that
there were people who actually wanted to
steal and defile the the consecrated
host right and then also the fact that
the picks was usually made from you know
precious metal as it should be
and so
for all these kind of reasons you would
want to keep watch so they would they
would usually hire
um you know like the church warden or
other men in the parish and uh to keep
watch all night um and and this was uh
in the middle ages this was an armed
watch that would actually keep and what
it sort of means is like you kind of go
there there are two kinds of people who
keep watch of the tomb of christ right
there's the mother of god who keeps
watching over the tomb this is
uh
this is in the father saint gregory
palamas talks about this um
but then there's also the soldiers right
the soldiers who keep watch over the
tomb yeah right and so it's like
which one am i sometimes yeah so the
body won't be still interesting yeah
yeah so so it's just interesting to see
how this these patterns kind of just
like manifest
themselves in these ways that christians
celebrate holy week
um and then of course all of this
culminates on holy uh with holy saturday
which is the day of baptism it's the day
that new christians are received into
the church
um and it's also the day of you know the
harrowing of hell the defeat of hell in
both the east and the west
for instance in anglo-saxon england uh
before the norman conquest there was a
really beautiful
basically it's basically a poetic
rewriting
of the gospel of nicodemus that they
would actually read
in old english they would actually read
this liturgically in the church on holy
saturday
so um so pretty cool stuff pretty cool
stuff and then
um holy saturday obviously that that
culminates in the easter vigil so
but i it seems like if you just study
the way that holy week has been
celebrated by christians in both east
and the west
everything sort of converges on the
sepulcher
and i think the two symbolic patterns
that seem to manifest the most
are
uh one this this
pattern of the removing of the garments
that that you talked about and then this
idea uh which is related to that of
christ as brighter like what happens on
a wedding night well the bride removes
her veil right
um
what's interesting is that you really
see like the difference between
you can see the difference so in so we
do have the notion of the glorious king
as christ ascends to heaven as christ
resurrects there's this sense in which
you know we see christ up in the dome
that you have this glorious king but you
also understand that
there is this glory like this position
that he holds goes through the cross and
goes through the tomb and that it
actually transforms the hierarchy like i
always
i talk about the notion that at the top
of the christian hierarchy is something
like self-sacrifice and that it's
actually not and it's not arbitrary once
you see it and you understand it you
realize that that's actually how reality
works reality actually holds together
through through self-sacrifice um and we
won't go into it too much into it here
you can find talks on my channel about
this but but
yeah self-sacrifice is the kind of
sacrifice that is the basis of marriage
right exactly of a true marriage of a
christian the whole idea of like a
sacrifice leading to a marriage
right that's that's the
because i mean that's the thing like
like uh putting
you know that idea of like the meta
desire right and the idea of like
putting your
put let let's let's take all that
tension and that disagreement between us
because we're competing for the same
resources whatever let's take that stuff
and let's put it on the scapegoat well
that's a temporary solution yeah
historically what's the long-term
solution that basically every human
culture has come up with
for saying how do we
share resources
in
a way that's going to be sustainable not
just for us but for the people who come
after us is through marriage
right
yeah
yeah and then you see this whole image
of this whole image of the the parents
or the the you know the parents that
give their attention their love to their
children and then don't see their
children as competition they see there's
a different relationship of
yeah of of giving and and love it's very
different so you can understand how it's
a different image of how reality holds
together one which is still based on
sacrifice yeah rather than because you
can see like even in terms of a family
you can understand how you've seen it
because sadly you see families like that
where
a black sheep in the family is useful
you know in order to
cohere the family it's like around that
around that one point yeah everything is
that person's fault and so then you're
able to cohere but that this is like you
said it's temporary and it's always
leading to some kind of uh
some kind of revenge at some you know in
some future at some future time but that
the true nature of of of a bond of love
which brings about self-sacrifice is the
one that is the only one that really
holds reality together and what happens
if you have that black sheep in like a
family or even like a friend group right
there
the more you commit to that the less
possibly becomes actually reconciled to
that person yeah because there's
actually a danger and i've seen this in
in families and friend groups and things
like this where there's a danger of if
we all decide we're going to forgive
this person then the thing that was
actually allowing us to cohere is gone
and then the group just dissolves
exactly yeah and
yeah then it's mayhem all all around
yeah yeah and so i think marriage is a
um
you know the famous monty python quote
strange women lying in pawns
distributing swords is not a basis for a
system of government well
i also don't believe that murder is a is
a basis for a system of government right
or like uh a basis for a culture um not
because there's not some truth to
gerard's ideas but because uh they're
incomplete right and i think that what
we see in holy week is the completion
right there is something of the
scapegoat there obviously christ
christ is both goats as they say on
lord's spirits
right but the focus the focal point of
all of that does seem to be for me uh in
the tomb and you could say the tomb that
is a
bridal chamber that's the place where
these things can actually join and
cohere yeah yeah
all right everybody i think that's a
great way to suit themselves
and so i wish everybody a i don't know
when we're gonna try to put that as soon
so for for all of you all that are on
the western uh calendar i wish you
uh a productive and a good holy week and
the same for all the orthodox watching
next week uh you know there's still just
yeah it's almost there's just a little
time left and i know lent has been hard
for a lot of people including me and
including richard this year and so we
pray for the grace to uh to uh to
struggle through and uh and to all find
ourselves in the glory of the of the
resurrection so thanks everybody for
your attention and we'll see you very
soon
this episode is part of a series of
discussions i've had with richard roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my youtube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
richard's second podcast which he hosts
in collaboration with father andrew
damick called amman sewell which looks
at the relationship between tolkien and
orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
me some ideas for creating some images
whether it be the king under the
mountain whether it be the grail or
beautiful ethiopian traditions i've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolicworld.store
and there will probably be more of those
to come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
universal history